15 días han pasado desde el inicio de
las hostilidades en la línea fronteriza
entre el estado venezolano de apure y el
departamento colombiano de arauca desde
entonces más de 6000 personas han huido
de la violencia hacia colombia las
razones los enfrentamientos entre el
ejército venezolano y grupos armados no
estatales ligados a las disidencias de
la antigua guerrilla colombiana de las
farc y la guerrilla del ejército de
liberación nacional
ln en juego está en el control de las
rutas de la droga la minería ilegal el
contrabando de combustible y el control
del río arauca por donde transitan los
negocios ilegales el gobierno venezolano
ha acusado a su contraparte colombiana
de esta situación dicen que son grupos
que fueron de la guerrilla de la farc
ustedes saben lo que ha pasado en buena
medida con el proceso de paz de colombia
nosotros ayudamos al proceso de paz
colombia por su parte acusa a venezuela
de disputarse el negocio de la droga con
estos grupos lo que está claro y los
ingredientes que hay una disputa entre
cuatro organizaciones por el mismo
negocio criminal está lln está la
eficiencia de la farc está la narco tal
y por supuesto también el interés que
tienen las fuerzas militares
bolivarianas respecto acción al voto
narcotráfico la realidad sin embargo
apunta hacia un tratado de paz fallido
en colombia y a la falta de presencia de
ambos estados en apuré y arauca apuré es
el estado más pobre de venezuela en
arauca la crisis del débil proceso de
paz propició que estos grupos impusieron
su ley en el territorio con todo esto la
población de ambos lados de la frontera
es la más perjudicada especialmente la
que huye de los enfrentamientos en el
lado venezolano el ejército venezolano
ha sido también acusado por ciudadanos
desplazados de atropellos a los derechos
humanos y ejecuciones extrajudiciales
hechos que investigará la propia
fiscalía venezolana